this is my friend laura and she's 80
years old
and this is my friend tiffany and she is
26
and we live in a retirement community
[Music]
i'm a part of the artisan residence
program at judson manor which is a
residential program where young
musicians get to live here rent free in
exchange for performing recitals and
concerts
when i tell people i live in the
retirement community i get a lot of
mixed reactions some people don't
believe me
other people
think it's a wonderful idea
i had not been a part of this community
more than
two days
i was in the lobby and they told me
about tiffany and i walked over and
introduced myself and i said do you like
dogs
oh she loves dogs
and tiffany and i became friends we just
formed a friendship
we'll talk about art we talk about
clothes
i don't wear shoe fashionable shoes
anymore but tiffany does and we talk
about shoes
laura to me is
like a grandma
and also a friend and a confidant
i don't think the age difference is
something that i am constantly thinking
about or that i'm aware of you don't
think oh i'm having dinner with this 100
year old and this 90 year old you know
i'm having dinner with my friend laura
and sarah
in a way it is almost like being in a
college dorm with the fact that there's
so many people here
from different places from different
backgrounds it might be a little bit
quieter
than a normal college dorm
but i think we still have just as much
fun
[Music]
you